the s p 500 is often hailed as the crown
jewel of personal finance if you want to
reliably grow your money and you don't
want to go through earnings reports or
experience extreme volatility the s p
500 is usually the top recommendation
everyone from youtubers like graham
steffen the deca billionaires like
warren buffett are massive fans of the s
p 500 and this is for good reason the s
p 500 it not only gives you a chance to
be invested in the leading american
companies but also an opportunity to
diversify amongst hundreds of companies
in other words like warren buffett says
investing in the s p 500 is basically
like betting on america and for the past
few hundred years betting on america
would have been extremely successful
however a few notable investors like
michael bury have actually been warning
us that index funds and passive
investing in general is one of the
biggest bubbles of our time now this
does not mean that you should sell
everything and go into cash but it's
also likely a good idea to look at why
exactly michael berry believes this so
here's the index fund bubble theory
one of the biggest factors people cite
in favor of the s p 500 is its long
history you hear things like the s p 500
has returned an average of 10.5 percent
for the past 100 years such statements
make you think that the s p 500 has been
a staple investment for basically a
century and that it has performed
strongly even through events such as
world war ii and the cold war but this
isn't exactly true while the s p 500 and
the dow jones have been around since the
early 1900s they were never popular
investment choices in fact there was no
easy way to even invest in the s p 500
if you were a retail investor you had to
go out and buy 500 different stocks
it wasn't until 1976 that john bogle the
founder of vanguard launched the first
u.s index fund that was available to
retail investors this means that for the
majority of the 1900s the s p 500 was
simply an indicator like the rsi or the
macd as opposed to an actual investment
also it's not like the s p 500 just took
off as soon as john bogal launched the
fund in fact interest in the fund was
horrendous john was hoping that 150
million dollars would flow into the fund
and ipo but in reality only 11.3 million
dollars flowed in not only did the fund
perform poorly from a financial
perspective but it was often the
laughing stock of wall street the s p
500 was generally associated with
unsophisticated investors who couldn't
even beat the market now it should be
noted that active funds themselves were
often not beating the market but this
didn't matter
the vast majority of people bought into
the narrative that active funds were
superior and that only losers who didn't
have access to active funds invested in
something like the s p 500 this was the
overwhelming sentiment up until the
early 2000s when we saw the dot-com
crash a lot of tech heavy funds got
obliterated or completely wiped out
while the s p 500 held up decently now
it should be noted that the s p 500
itself was down about 50 percent but
this was far better than a lot of
internet companies that were down 80 90
95
this led to more interest in index funds
and consequently more index funds and
etfs were launched but it wasn't until
the 2008 financial recession and warren
buffett's famous bet against active
funds that index funds really took off
just take a look at this graph
showcasing the assets under management
by etfs in 2003 this number was just 200
billion dollars worldwide today this
number stands at over 10 trillion
dollars and much of this growth has
happened within the past decade so
clearly index fund investing is not some
tried and true strategy that has been
around for a hundred years really it
wasn't till the last two decades that
index fund investing became a popular
strategy and this short history opens up
index fund investing to a massive slew
of problems starting with asset
inflation
while active investing often gets a lot
of slack nowadays for not even beating
the market when you really think about
it it's actually active investing that
made index funds so great in the first
place the reason that index funds were
able to post such great numbers
throughout the 1900s was because index
funds were basically a conglomeration of
active investors favorite stocks for
example if a lot of active investors
really like coca-cola the stock would go
up and the market cap would go up and it
would be included in the s p 500.
conversely if a lot of active investors
did not like coca-cola the stock would
go down and the market cap would go down
and it would be kicked from the s p 500.
so it was really the active investors
that indirectly determined which stocks
would be in the index and the index was
basically a consensus of the active
investors with the rise of passive
investing however this is no longer the
case many of the companies in the s p
500 receive a massive amount of buying
pressure simply because they're part of
the index for example have you guys ever
heard of nielsen holdings leon's bank
corporation at work warner or pinnacle
west capital
i doubt any of these stocks have massive
active investor bases however they boast
quite a bit of volume borg warner boasts
an average daily volume of 2.16 million
shares and nielsen holdings boasts an
average daily volume of 10.72 million
shares this correlates to tens of
millions of dollars if not hundreds of
millions of dollars on a daily basis and
much of this volume is buying pressure
from passive investors who simply invest
at amount every day or week these guys
aren't looking at the company's pe
ratios or revenue growth or its profit
growth or any of the factors that
determine whether the company is a good
investment despite this they continue to
buy in on a regular basis just because
it's part of the index i don't think i
need to explain how this leads to these
stocks being inflated over time this
leads to bad companies sticking around
in the index for much longer than they
should and it prevents great companies
from entering the index when they should
this concern also carries over into the
biggest companies in the index as well
for 9 and 10 companies in the s p 500
their largest single shareholder is an
index fund provider
this means that stocks like apple google
amazon and facebook receive
extraordinary amounts of buying pressure
from passive investors now there's no
doubt that these are phenomenal
companies but it's likely that even
these companies would be valued much
lower if they weren't part of the index
for example apple might be worth two
trillion dollars instead of three
trillion dollars if it wasn't for
constant buying pressure from passive
investors this eventually leads to a
much bigger problem than simply asset
inflation
if passive investing gets big enough
which it might already be index funds
will start performing well not because
the companies in the index are
fundamentally performing well but simply
because of supply and demand and that's
a rabbit hole that you don't want to go
down
another major shortfall of the s p 500
is that it's not actually that
diversified but wait a minute 500
companies is a lot of companies if we
split 100 into 500 companies each
company would only get 20 cents this
means that you're only risking 0.2
percent of your investment with any
single company right well this would be
true if the s p 500 was an equal weight
index but it's not apple alone accounts
for nearly 7 of the index and the top 50
companies account for over 50 of the
index this means that the other 450
companies don't even account for half of
your investment this lack of
diversification significantly
accentuates the asset inflation problem
also not only do these top companies
account for the majority of the s p 500
in terms of weight but they also account
for the majority of its returns in fact
just five companies facebook amazon
apple microsoft and google have
accounted for 40 of the s p 500 total
returns over the past five years another
way to put this is that one percent of
the s p 500 accounted for 40 of its
success
if we just remove these five companies
from the index the s p 500 annual
average return would drop from 9.68
down to 5.76
now this is already quite substantial
but the contribution becomes even bigger
if we consider the top 100 companies to
make this comparison let's take a look
at the s p 100 which is exactly what it
sounds like it's the top 100 companies
in the s p 500 in this graph the s p 500
is the orange line and the s p 100 is
the candles as we can see sometimes the
s p 500 is winning and other times the s
p 100 is winning but over the long term
they're basically identical over the
past 32 years the s p 500 has only beat
now at the s p 100 by a mere 20 percent
this means that 98.3 percent of the s p
500 returns over the past 32 years are
from the top 100 companies in the s p
500 where things really get interesting
though is when we compare both of these
to the nasdaq 100 if you're not familiar
with what the nasdaq 100 is it's
basically the top 100 tech companies in
the s p 500 and if we add the nasdaq to
our graph this is what we get as you can
see the nasdaq literally performed five
times better than the s p 500 over the
past 32 years and given that the s p 500
basically includes all the stocks that
are in the nasdaq this means that the
other 400 companies in the s p 500 are
straight up holding back performance and
this makes perfect sense when you
consider the s p 500 include stocks like
atnt citigroup american airlines and
general motors which are down on a
multi-decade basis fortunately such
companies account for a smaller weight
of the s p 500 than the top performers
but this doesn't change that billions of
dollars are flowing into such companies
not because they're top performers but
just because they're part of the s p 500
and as more people start investing in
indices and grow their positions this
just becomes a bigger and bigger problem
at the end of the day index funds may
not actually be the safe haven that
they're often pitched as index funds
have a relatively short history of
actually being invested into and the
rise of passive investing is likely
leading to significant asset inflation
not to mention you can get far better
returns by simply investing it into the
top performers of the s p 500 this is
why many top investors aren't big fans
of the s p 500 or are straight up
calling for a full-on collapse like
michael bury with that being said should
you stop investing it in the s p 500
well this is not financial advice and
i'm just some guy on the internet but
here's what i think while the s p 500
does have the risk of being the
centerpiece of a massive bubble i
strongly believe that the risk of not
investing is way higher than the risk of
investing it in the s p 500 the only
thing that is guaranteed to go down in
real value is cash and this is more
relevant than ever before given the sky
high inflation
and currently one of the best ways we
know to mitigate this risk is to invest
in the s p 500 which has thus far
produced moderate yet reliable returns
now if you're willing to stomach some
more volatility i think the nasdaq 100
may be an even better choice and if
you're willing to take on even more risk
you might consider investing in just the
top 20 or 30 tech companies along with
some bitcoin and ethereum but as a base
i think everyone should at least have
some exposure to the s p 500 that way
your money is not just burning away in
some low interest savings account but
that's just what i think do you guys
think the s p 500 is just a massive
bubble comment that down below also drop
a like if you're a fan of investing and
of course consider checking out our
international channels to watch our
videos in other languages and consider
subscribing to see more questions that
logically answered but until then i'm
hari and i'll see you guys on the next
one
you